les liants fabrique de loudes fabrique
de l'oubli
le cinéma toujours fabriquer des
souvenirs une fête ses 90 ans ce jeudi
jean luc godard ses soixante années de
cinéma et presque autant de coups de
gueule sa victime préférée la télévision
ils ont tous les langlois ils ont tué
trop ils ont terminé devant la
télévision les journalistes
godard n'a jamais caché son mépris pour
la petite lucarne synonyme de mal absolu
wen un contrat en 1967 il est interviewé
par le journaliste henry chapier au
festival de cannes
et dès le début de l'entretien il
recadre le cadreur la preuve a créé la
télé payante et l'emploi à temps d'arrêt
autre coup de gueule en 1980 cette fois
en direction des médias après la
diffusion du journal télévisé
le réalisateur critique le traitement de
l'information face à lui
daniel bilalian à leurs jeunes
journalistes disent que les gens de
cinéma ont le temps de s'intéresser à
l'actualité vous qui êtes un jaune un
cinéma grassi un cinéaste pardon je vais
y arriver
engagé dit on si on voyait à la
télévision plutôt que d'entendre qu'on
parlait moins qu'on voyait plus je pense
que je pourrais revenir mais comme on
fait que parler moi j'ai rien vu le tout
après daniel bilalian c'est au tour de
philippe labro d'être la cible de godard
en 1982 c'est la guerre des malouines
entre l'argentine et le royaume uni le
cinéaste dénoncent un flux
d'informations incompréhensible j'ai
commencé mon journal jean luc en disant
informations contradictoires et confuse
argentine dyn échanges londres autre
chose
informations contradictoires ou la blair
de savoir ces informations dans
trajectoire et moi chef d'antenne de je
ne sais pas ce qui se passe après la
leçon de journalisme
le cours de cinéma cette fois c'est yves
mourousi le présentateur du journal de
tf1 qui en fait les frais en 1985
comme ça je peux voir l'image voilà il
faudrait cadre est comme ça en enlever
une lumière par exemple ici et
simplement
moi je parvins dit leur poids rives au
revoir et ya de matra heures jean-luc
godard c'est plus de 140 oeuvres à son
actif parmi elles des films des séries
mais aussi des clips et des courts
métrages godard deuxième leçon était
mauvais la première fois c'est la télé
[Musique]